what I want to relate today is my
experience recent learning about
building packages and for elliptic
curves so a little background to start
sort of why I'm interested conic
sections have been well understood for a
long time this is a modernized figure
that Apollonius did in his work conics
back more than 2,000 years ago and also
we've known about solutions to the
quadratic equation in the distant past
even before the algebra existed to
express it in this nice neat modern form
but an interesting aspect of conic
sections
shortly after de car married algebra
with geometry so that we could express
curves as the zero sets of algebraic
functions the story was kind of
completed for the conic sections we can
even find all the rational points on
conics and this is a classic rational
parameterization of the circle the basic
idea is you start with one known point
with fractional or rational coordinates
and you pick a point on the y axis
that's also rational and that line
intersects the curve in one other place
and that has to be rational too because
you end up with a root of a quadratic if
one of them is rational the other has to
be rational
so this accomplishment with very little
change in the basic concept you can
rationalize points on ellipses and
hyperbolas all the conic sections
creating a map essentially from Q to the
rational points on the figure and that's
sort of the end of the story there's not
much more to say about conics they were
completely understood from an algebraic
standpoint cubic curves are much more
interesting the general cubic equation
of course has more terms and it took up
until the sixteenth century before the
equivalent of the quadratic formula
could be figure
this group of colourful Italian
mathematicians of the early Renaissance
figured out a formula for the cubic
equation in the quartic equation and you
can see why it's a little harder than
the quadratic formula
there's mathematic as version of the
cubic equation and of course it's hard
to do that right and that's just the
case where you have an equation in a
single variable or the curve y equals ax
cubed plus BX plus C so enter elliptic
curves really a 20th century invention
had to wait for the work of the 19th
century and now analysts wire stops
being an important one an elliptic curve
is a non-singular cubic curve in two
variables over a field and the non
singularity we'll see why it's important
it means essentially that the derivative
exists everywhere and we need the
derivative in order to get the structure
that we're looking for so this is in the
so called viral short form it turns out
that under a suitable change of
variables the general equation can be
transformed into that form that
preserves the group structure and when I
teach this to undergraduates this seems
to provide intuition the blue line is a
regular old cubic curve and what we're
doing really is taking the plus and
minus roots of the cubic so the elliptic
curve is a solution to y is equal to
plus or minus the square root of the
right hand side and so in wire strands
form it's symmetric about the x-axis so
what makes these things interesting well
first of all I think the study of
elliptic curves motivates the study of a
lot of interesting mathematics if you
want to study the geometry you end up in
algebraic geometry in algebraic topology
if you want to study the number theory
you end up being driven into a theory of
complex variables complex analysis but
even more so in my study of these
interesting curves they illuminate the
deep connections between these diverse
branches
and they give a concrete example
sometimes studying the topics topology
algebraic geometry algebraic topology in
the abstract can be difficult but the
family of elliptic curves gives us a
concrete world to work in also Lipton
curves have a wide-ranging use in both
pure and applied mathematics there are
cryptographic algorithms based on
elliptic curves they're used in the
integer factoring algorithm in fact
that's built into Mathematica there's a
Leinster is elliptic curve integer
factoring and they elliptic curves a
certain form of them were used in the
proof of hermas Las Vegas Last Theorem
and elliptic curves continue to be an
active area of research the virtuous
Winterton dier 1 million dollar prize
conjecture is still out there is a deep
theorem about the structure of elliptic
curves and there's active research
papers coming out frequently so this
makes these curves interesting to me
both as a area of study in as an area of
motivating undergraduate research so
what makes them different because of the
structure of an elliptic curve even even
though we cannot easily find the
rational points in fact that's one of
the hard problems we can do an algebra
of points by defining the sum of two
points on a curve to be the reflection
essentially of the third point of
intersection of the line between those
points with the axis so if I back this
up a little bit we have points P and Q
that you draw a line through them the
third point of intersection isn't the
sum but it's the reflection of that
point about the axis of symmetry that's
defined as the sum and when you do that
it turns out you get a group structure
with a little bit of extra work but what
about adding a point to itself well that
creates a slight challenge I get these
to line up yeah how do you add a point
to itself well you don't have a line
anymore but you use the tangent line and
it turns out that even when you're not
working in the Rio in the Cartesian
plane you can still algebra
really do a formal derivative to
construct a tangent line in this case
the tangent line is counted as a double
point of intersection and that then you
have the intersection of the tangent
line is a Third Point and you reflect it
and you get P plus Q so that's the
geometric idea of adding points but to
complete the picture to get a real group
structure we need to look at projective
space so the idea basically is you
convert your cubic polynomial to
homogeneous form which means introducing
a new variable so that the powers the
total degree of each term is the same
and then if you let the that it newly
introduced variable Z be one it's clear
you get the original curve back so all
the points with coordinates XY 1
correspond to the real solutions in the
original equation but you get a new
point a single point that satisfies the
equation where X is zero Y is anything
and Z is zero and that's the point we
call the point and infinity and acts as
a group identity so when that's done we
now get a algebraic group structure
where this is the identity it's not too
hard to see that it's commutative
because the line through two points is
the line through two points no matter
which one I take first we have an
identity the inverses are shown in this
picture P and minus P are inverses
because when you add them you get to
this point at infinity and associativity
works too although it's hard to to see
but the beauty of it is even though the
this law was derived geometrically it
has an algebraic form of the addition
law that's valid over any field
including fields where there's no visual
representation of the curve so there's
the algebraic form we're adding two
points we compute the slope of the line
change in Y over change in X where the
Y's are different with the X's are
different and we use the implicit
differentiation to get the slope in the
case of a tangent point and then the
second equations there give the
coordinates of X and y of the sum in
terms of those things we just calculated
well surprisingly that can be proven
algebraically to give an abelian group
it's closed in the field we have an
identity we have inverses
we have associativity and so this is
where elliptic curves get interesting is
we can now apply algebraic ideas to the
geometry so the purpose of the package I
built is to provide a set of utilities
or basic support over the standard
fields the rational numbers the real
numbers the complex numbers prime fields
and the general finite field where I
provided an overloaded plus circle plus
operator to signify the addition of
points and an overloaded circle times
operator to signify thus integer
multiplication and I chose this over
overloading the regular times and plus
in Mathematica because we're not in a
field we're really are working in is is
a group which of course has a
representation as a Z module so it was
more I thought it was more appropriate
to use these symbols for point addition
and integer multiplication which simply
means adding a point to itself over and
over again we provide the ability to
determine the order of a point that's
the in the usual sense how many times do
I add a point to itself before I get
back to the identity code to provide a
solution to the discrete logarithm
problem this is known to be a hard
problem and the algorithm here is a
standard one so it's not good enough to
break cryptography schemes with and also
some routines that support cryptographic
and number theoretic applications but
the idea I've been working with these
curves for a while and I've written a
lot of code this was an effort to start
to consolidate this into a shareable
package and mathematic is ability to do
arithmetic over well many different
fields particularly its ability to do
modular polynomial arithmetic and
modular polynomial algebra makes it well
suited to research in this area so what
if I provide the basic design is there
are two data types introduced in the
package and EC curve with three
arguments a B and F a and B are the
parameters of the curve and F describes
the field that we're working over and
there's also a new data type or a new
head EC point which is used to represent
the individual points on the curve one
of the key functions is setting the
current curve set EC with a curve
establishes the currently active curve
and now we can work in a very simplified
form since the curve is implicit we can
use operator notation to do the elliptic
curve arithmetic and these the
underlying code is field neutral and
then hidden private functions take care
of the dirty work of working in
different fields one of my design
choices was for fields of prime order
the arithmetic is essentially just
modular arithmetic and so I implemented
special routines to do that rather than
using the finite fields package just
because it's a lot easier to deal with
the integers then dealing with the GF
symbols in a finite fields package but
it works also or at least should work I
guess using the the finite fields
package to create points with
coefficients in the finite field and
parameterize the curve with parameters a
B in the finite field if you probably
didn't notice but in the group law all
that's used is addition and
multiplication so just the field
operations as well as the negation of
additive inverse
and the multiplicative inverse so the
group law is valid over any field so
with no change the code works the same
over R or a finite field okay so some
examples of how the package works
there's a definition of a curve over a
small prime finite field we define the
curve and we can verify that it's it
actually is a valid curve we can define
a couple of points and verify that those
are actually points on the curve we can
determine the order algebraic water over
the points that is what I have to
multiply them by to get back to the
identity we can use this nice infix
operator notation to generate a linear
combination of points this kind of setup
is common commonly occurs in algorithms
for elliptic curves we can figure out
that J invariant for a curve this is a
invariant that identifies if two
elliptic curves have the same J
invariant and there's a rational map
that map's between one on the other and
the group structure of those curves is
the same I thought with the end of
October coming up that was a curious J
invariant I didn't plan that
anyway we can also determine the order
of the group there's a theorem due to
Helmut Haas that bounds the order of the
group close to the degree of the field
in this case it says that this order of
the group must be between 6 57 and 763
and we can actually determine the group
order I'm using a fairly simple method
to do this currently
oops gonna execute the right thing yeah
so the actual order of this group it has
754 points including the identity okay
so this is all over a small finite field
another interesting example this yeah
back before day car math early
mathematician by name of bash a
developed a duplication formula for
points that satisfy that relationship
the difference of a square and a cube
equal to a rational number and so we can
sort of duplicate his work to find the
curve to find one rational point on the
curve and then double the points that is
add the point to itself would be the
idea in modern elliptic curve
terminology he wasn't thinking in those
terms but as you can see the using
mathematic is exact rational arithmetic
we can keep track of exactly what's
going on and it turns out that's
important for a area of research looking
at what's called the height of a point
which is the essentially the logarithm
of the worst case length of the reduced
rational numbers involved but since
again mathematic is nice symbolic
capability I can actually apply this
doubling to a arbitrary point and get
back instead of numbers get back a
formula that's when a one form of the
formula that bash a discovered back in
1621
so the point addition in the point
multiplication also works symbolically
with reasonable limitations
okay a cryptographic example the
el-gamal method involves using a couple
of simple multiples of a point and with
again with the notation that the package
supports this is the entire encoding
process we multiply an integer times a
point and also a point plus an integer
times another point where I find a
random point in a random integer
decoding works the same way I do
negative scale factor of a point again
that works or any field and also do a
point addition and so what does this
look like I set up a field and figure
out its order and that order in the
number of points in this example is an
important parameter I generate a public
key and the public key in this
implementation I pick a private number s
and then pick a random point and create
an S times that point and s becomes the
private key and the two points become
the public key those are distributed
public key is distributed and a message
is read in secret message and then the
encoding simply takes the message and
applies the algorithm to it and produces
point pairs for each numeric message
that's encoded and then of course if
this is was a cryptographic scheme this
would be what would be public and any
eavesdropper who tried to read this
message would essentially have to get s
back the secret number S which means
they'd have to solve the elliptic curve
discrete log problem which is as far as
we know hard to do over a sufficiently
size field and then the decoding
algorithm is applied and turning numbers
back into messages and this is the
correctly decoded message so this is
version 1.0 as of three days ago nothing
worked but that's the way stuff happens
right so we now have a working package
where I need to go with this to make it
really useful is to provide support over
the complex numbers there's some
functions if you're familiar with that
are functions in the complex plane the
virus routes P function and its
derivative it turns out those are
related by a cubic curve equation also
providing some extra support for a
number of theory research the VAE
pairing is which maps a pair of points
to a point on the unit circle and right
now I've got an implementation of scoffs
algorithm for determining the order of a
group it's not very efficient for very
large fields many years ago L keys and
Atkins improved scoffs algorithm and to
make this useful for people working at
the cryptographic levels I would need to
implement that algorithm so these are my
prime references if you're interested at
all in elliptic curves and know nothing
about them elliptic curves by Larry
Washington is a really gentle
introduction sort of one of my goals is
to implement most of the book in the
package eventually piece by piece and
then for the number theoretic side
Joseph Joseph Silverman's excellent book
rational points on elliptic curves those
are my two prime sources
that's all I have to present at this
point I wanted to leave time for
questions and I have one question for
you if you're interested in this area
I'm interested in what you'd like to see
add it to this package